we say to people that I don't I think
it's about 300 songs that John and I
wrote together we never had a dry
session we'd always come in and we never
went away from the session going
couldn't get it today we always finish
to some she's pretty remarkable I lost
my little girl it's the first song I
wrote that was very simple three chords
four chords and yeah it was real early
little kind of rock and roll thing I got
a guitar when I was early teens and I
learned a couple of chords I learned a G
and a g7 C and an F and we're using
those chords I made up this little song
called I lost my little girl people
asked me whether it was about losing my
mother at that early age which I don't
know like a psychiatrist might have a
field day with that but I certainly
didn't think it was at the time it could
have been yesterday
all my troubles seemed so far and I had
two melodies a song yesterday in my
brain and I didn't have any words so I
called it scrambled eggs scrambled eggs
or my baby ha
I think difference between me and a lot
of people is they they often dream about
music but they don't remember but for
some reason this melody just kept going
around and round my brain so I was near
a piano so I kind of remembered it and
blocked out some chords a couple of
months later I put some words to it
yesterday when John and I John and I
were getting together we were kind of
showing each other what we'd written and
and this was one I I said to him what I
got this idea and I started off with it
and we finished it together so it was a
very early Lennon McCartney song having
a collaborator one thing's great if you
get stuck with with something you can
just say what do you think of this you
know and you can kick it around together
my song started she was just 17 she's
never been a beauty queen and we kind of
looked at each other's like I said I
don't really like that line so we
changed her she's just 17 you know what
I mean which makes more sense even
though you probably don't know what I
mean so we changed it to that and they
that started our songwriting partnership
most of it was start from scratch but
sometimes one of us would just have an
idea
like of the first couple of lines and
then we just sit down and work it but a
lot of it we just came in and just
started talking about what would my
world write about and then we just sit
down there were three quick sessions
it's normally like about three hours and
we'd finished something you know from
beginning to end with the chords and the
melody and the words
yeah I mean 300 was just the ones I
wrote with jump since then I've written
lots more and you do forget him yeah and
that is my excuse and I love her I
brought that I'd written it and I
brought it into the studio and I was
showing the guys George Martin our
producer said it'd be nice to have an
intro on it you know a nice to have a
little something bleeding the song again
so we're sitting around thinking and
George Harrison just want more about
this to do to do and I think you know
that song wouldn't be anything without
that he just came up with it so that was
the kindest pace we worked at because
nobody ever knew what song we were bout
to record then me and John would know
because we were written at the previous
week with George and Ringo and the
producer wouldn't know what we were so
he said it was like this you know we'd
shown and in the space of about 20
minutes they'd go OK and then we just
recorded so it was very fast process and
that was very cool cool move you know he
just made up that riff when I say if you
think about the song without that riff
wouldn't be half as good
[Music]
the Rigby was when I was really little I
lived on what we call a housing estate
which is like the project there were a
lot of old ladies
and I enjoyed sitting around with these
older ladies because they they had these
great stories in this case about world
war ii you know and one in particular
who I used to kind of just visit and I
kind of go shopping for her you know she
couldn't get out to anybody so I
remember her so I had that figure in my
mind of a sort of lonely old lady and
over the years I'd met a couple others
and I don't know maybe the loneliness
made me sort of empathize with them I
thought it was a great character so I
started this song about lonely old lady
who picks up the rice in the church who
never really gets the dreams in her life
and then I added in the the priest the
vicar father McKenzie and so there was
just the two characters you know so he's
nice he was like writing a short story
and up but it was based basically on
these old ladies that I had known as a
kid father McKenzie in the song
originally had father McCartney but when
I came to finish it up with John I
brought it to John and we were playing
it around and I said I don't want it I
don't want to call this father McCarty
because it's like my dad just he's been
confusing and he said no it's fine I
said no I don't like it
so I said okay let's change so we got
the phone book we just went right down
to sort of McCarty McCarney McCarney and
look for something muck something and
the next one was like McKenzie said
that's better so became father McKenzie
sometimes I do that you know just to
block it out so you so you don't spend
forever trying to figure out the exact
lyric you just combine it so it could be
Barbara Hawkins Miss Daisy
and you just leave it like that and
there you go I don't really like that so
I was looking around for another name
this is a kind of strange story about
that because I I want it i like the name
Eleanor we've been working with an
actress called Ellen LeBron and the
Beatles film help I like the name
Eleanor I was looking for this Ellen up
Papa
to make the rhythm so I'm looking for
this nice surname and I happened to be
in Bristol and that I saw a shop that
said Rigby so there are great Eleanor
Rigby so now I had the name of my main
character but then years later somebody
else is researching this and they said
you know in that village where you used
to where John used to live there's a
graveyard in the church and there is a
gravestone there too an Eleanor Rigby
so I said did I subconsciously know that
name why would I go around searching for
it I don't know I think it's maybe a
coincidence but there is a gravestone in
Liverpool and please call Walton were me
and John met to sale and a ruby
[Music]
then the life was a song that John had
started and he kind of had the first
verse and this often happened one of us
would have a little bit of an idea and
instead of sitting down and sweating it
we just bring it to the other one and
kind of finish it together because you
could ping-pong you know you got an idea
then he get an idea that's good you know
and so I say he had the first verse I
read the news today oh boy and we sat in
my music room in London and just started
playing around with it got a second
verse and then we got to what was going
to lead into the middle and you were
kind of looked at each other and kind of
knew we were being a little bit kind of
edgy when we sort of said I'd love to
turn you we kind of knew like this would
have an effect it worked and then we put
another section I had woke up fell out
of bed trying to calm across my head so
I had that section so we put that in and
then finish the song up and then did a
big sort of epic recording of it with
big full orchestra and everything you
know and then did that crescendo thing
in the middle of it with the orchestra
which was an idea I'd had because I've
been I've been talking people reading
about sort of avant-garde music and I
ate whole stuff crazy ideas and I came
up with this idea I said to the
orchestra
you should start all of you in which
they're all looking at me puzzled we've
got a real Symphony Orchestra and London
who were used to playing your Beethoven
and his mates and this crazy guy out of
a group and I'm saying all you gotta do
is you saw everyone start on the lowest
note your instrument could play and work
your way up to the highest at your own
pace just if you want to go look up
that's final good you know that was too
puzzling for them
they're all looking at me and orchestras
don't like that kind of thing they like
it written down and they'd like to know
exactly what was supposed to do so
George Martin the producers realized
that you kept the random aspect but he
said to the people you should be well
this note at this point in the song and
then he should have got to this note
this note and he left the random thing
so that's why it sounds like a chaotic
to the squirrel you know yeah no that
was that was an idea based on the sort
of avant-garde stuff that I was into at
the time Hey Jude
don't make it John and his wife Cynthia
had divorced and I felt a bit sorry for
this son who was now a little bit you
know a child of a divorce I was driving
out to see the Sun and Cynthia one day
and I was I was thinking about the boy
whose name's Julian Julian then and I
started this idea hey Jules don't make
it bad so it couldn't be okay you know
it's like a reassurance song so that was
the idea that I got driving out to see
them I saw them and then I came back and
worked on the song some more but I like
to name Jude I didn't realize it meant
Jewish she does actually I nearly got
into trouble because we we put it up on
on a window of our shop we had a little
shop because we were into fashion
would you believe for a while on the
shop window we put Hey Jude so that
people going by on the buses would see
what's that you know intriguing ah and
then it was all right well I got this
furious phone call from this guy
mr. lamb who was Jewish they said what
are you doing how dare you do this is
also Hey Jude
because in Hitler's day in the Nazi
thing Juden raus meant Jews out so and I
didn't connect is I actually heard the
name first in in one of the musicals and
I like the name anybody rings me up when
he's furious how he's doing this you
know making followed the chose we got
enough for I said no no no no wait a
minute I swear to you it's nothing like
that he said I'm gonna send my son
around to beat you up
I said hey baby it's cool it down
nothing to do with that said you'll hear
when you hear the record it's just a
name in a song and it's all cool but of
course I you know it suddenly was
alerted to the fact that it would have
caused him a lot of problems because his
family will have experienced that you
know firsthand probably anybody calmed
him down he was cool
and his son didn't come round to beat me
up whenever I do a new tour I think well
I'll just switch up all the songs but
then I go I've got to do Hey Jude
because it is such fun and it's great
handing that over to the audience you
know and you know what the greatest
thing is you feel this sense of
community and in these times when it's a
little dark and it's people are sort of
separated by politics and stuff it's so
fantastic to see them all come together
singing the end of Hey Jude so I'm very
happy about that so I keep it in the
show helter skelter yeah I heard it on
the car radio the other day did say wow
you know it is I could see why people
would think it was the precursor of
heavy metal how it came about was I had
read in a music paper that the who had
had done a really heavy track and Pete
Townshend of the who was quoted saying
it this is that we've just made the
dirtiest loudest filthiest song ever so
I was kind of jealous
I didn't hear their song I still don't
know what song he was referring to but I
went in the studio said guys we've done
it to a song cos dirtier and filthier
and louder than the WHO and think about
the real stuff was that when I look back
on or what we've produced there's no two
songs that are alike whereas you know a
lot of record artists will find a great
formula and they the next three singles
are kind of the same song you know but
we just were young guys and we would
have got bored doing that under the
worst thing ever seen as we're allowed
in the studio allowed to play guitars
and things the worst thing ever would
have been just to sit around bored so we
we always changed whatever we were about
to do and did something different so I
had this helter-skelter thing and we did
that and yeah it is pretty raw you know
it's pretty screamy
it was good to do we did a lot of takes
on it so it was hard on Ringo you know
I'm one of the I'm one of the takes you
can hear him right at the end he says
I've got blisters on my fingers
she'd been drumming so hard and so loud
you know that well yeah I wonder whether
you know heavy metal bands heard that
and thought that's the way to go like
you know loud rock and roll basically
and I know the ac/dc guys and they're
loud have you seen them live Oh baby
that's that's one of the joys being in a
band is you get to plug in electric
guitar and turn it up just as loud as
you want and it's such a sort of cool
feeling that I could see why you'd form
a group based around that idea Blackbird
I was sitting around my acoustic guitar
and I'd heard about the civil rights
troubles that were happening in the 60s
in Alabama Mississippi Little Rock in
particular so that was in my mind and I
just thought it'd be really good if I
could write something that if you ever
reached any of the people going through
those problems it might kind of give
them a little bit of hope so I wrote
Blackbird and in England a bird is a
girl so I was thinking a black girl
going through this you know you now's
your time to arise you you know set
yourself free and take these broken
wings one of the nice things about music
is that you know the lot of people
listening to you are going to take
seriously what you're saying in the song
so I'm very proud of the fact that the
Beatles output is always really pretty
positive and there's hardly anything in
there that sort of says goon screw your
parents or whatever you know it's always
pretty let it be Hey Jude
so it's hopefully a good message I
particularly like that and you sometimes
around writing songs I will think
there's people out who were going
through some problems and hopefully
people out there will listen to it and
think oh yeah it's not just me alone
going through this you know this is
something and also something that I can
fix that was another dream song actually
I'd been overdoing it you know it's the
60s and we were just getting crazed and
stuff a lot of the time and so I went to
bed and wasn't feeling too great inside
my in myself and in the dream my mother
came into me in the dream and she died
maybe 10 years previously and so when
someone who you've lost comes back to
you in a dream it's a miraculous moment
you know because you you with them and
you your mind doesn't say wait a minute
you shouldn't be here you just with them
and so it was really nice you know cuz
there's my mom very emotional and she
seemed to realize is this all going on
in my mind of course but you know forget
that she seemed to realize that I was
going through struggles and she said
it's gonna be ok it's all really gonna
be ok she said just just let it be I
would I felt great and woke up with her
was that what I remember the dreams of
what did she say let it be and then I
sat down the piano and wrote the song it
had a lot of emotion because of who'd
said it and my situation so that kind of
translated to the record and I think
that's why a lot of people like it they
feel somehow that kind of magic comes
through
I don't know you know just sometimes you
just sit down at a piano and sometimes
there isn't a piano so you play the
guitar it's not like a formula it's just
what you fancy at the time and that
particular song there was a piano in my
room so I just sort of wrote it on the
piano and it still is a piano song when
I do it live it's a piano song those
times after the 60s were pretty high and
you know a lot of people were getting
high so to me it's just like a fantasy
song hey girl come on let's get high now
I must admit it could get a little bit
embarrassing because I got grandkids and
he's be gone yeah so when do we do it in
life I kind of go let's get high on life
disclaimer there you know but at the
time it was just about the times and
multicolored band and it's a it's very
much a period piece but it goes down
well and one of my guys rang me up said
hey you know this we've got a problem
what oh the BBC just banned hi hi they
won't play it why not
well it's drug-related and they're
pretty straight-laced you know one of my
two band records I you know I can see
why and if I say
I read after John died they'd been a lot
of talk about who did what and who liked
who did the Beatles argue and or I was
almost buying into this idea that me and
John was sort of fighting all the time
but I I just remembered it wasn't true
so I wrote this song about you know if
you were here you might say this or
those but I know better I know I
remember well some of the things we did
I was really it was really for me
thinking about John and just thinking
you know what we we had a great
relationship and like any family there's
always arguments
there's always disputes but in the end
you know we loved each other and I
wanted to do I wanted to make a song
where I actually said I love you too
John and so that was that song again
it's quite emotional you know because it
came from a real feeling about him and
wanted to correct the record kind of in
my mind as much as in anyone else's mind
and there are some photos from that
period which are really beautiful and
there's just him and me working and you
can see we loved each other so but you
know when she wants all these rumors go
about you almost playing into them
yourself anyway so that song can I help
me set the record straight
[Applause]
I was in Excel writing moved and it was
up in Scotland I just thought okay I
just gotta go somewhere and try and
write a song and we happen to have a
little pony did was called jet on the
farm I was on a farm in Scotland and
actually took my guitar and hiked up
this great big hill I just kind of find
myself a place there which is in the
middle of nature and to satyr and just
started making up a song you know it's
not one of those songs that I even when
I sing it now
I don't kind of know what where all the
words came from I know where jet came
from and I like the name the words are I
cut probably about me and my
father-in-law you know early days of
getting married and when your
father-in-law is kind of a nuisance and
you kind of hey so he's probably the
major in it but you know it's only a
song so you kind of work you work you
things out that one was written halfway
up a mountain in Scotland then record
recorded in Nigeria yeah I was wondering
where to record and I fancied getting
out of England so I asked my record
label which is am I to supply me with a
list of all the studios they had around
the world I knew they had a lot and one
was in China what was in Rio de Janeiro
one was in Lagos Nigeria
so our yeah later come on because I like
African music a lot I love the rhythms
of African music and so I chose that not
realizing that it would be really basic
little studio and we kind of built half
the studio they didn't have a vocal
booth you are you're going to booth to
isolate your voice they didn't have one
so we had to explain to them you take
some Ward and you do this and you get
some glass and you put it in like that
so we built the vocal booth but it was
kind of nice I like the primitive aspect
of it and being in Africa was pretty
interesting experience if you got three
hours out
about it
[Music]
I don't know is the one that opens the
album and it's much more angst-ridden
again you know you you sit down to write
a song and you think oh I'm not gonna
write anything that's like too sad or
desperate people are gonna think I'm
desperate but but you go know people
like that I like that so I'm gonna write
something you can often take a moment
you remember where you had like at let's
say an argument and you think you think
of that situation and you work it out in
the song so just by saying the opening
lines I've got crows up my window dogs
at my door I don't think I can take any
more that makes you feel better and you
suddenly oh it's a song and you you're
crafting it into a vehicle that kind of
puts all those thoughts in there or all
your kind of troubles and woes so you
kind of work you work your things out
and songs one of the great things about
writing songs it's almost like a therapy
you can go in kind of angry or sad and
you put all of that in the song and it
kind of makes the song better because
it's real feelings in it and when you
finish the song you feel a lot better
[Music]